[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
las múltiples crisis en Haití llevaron a
su vecino República Dominicana a tomar
medidas pero hacerlo significa el
bloqueo de un importante corredor
terrestre que une a dos pueblos que
comparten una misma isla y le pone
además una barrera al comercio en
dajabón una de las plazas comerciales
más importantes los locales aprovechan
los días de mercado para vender y
comprar sus productos mientras crece el
temor de mayor inestabilidad social en
Haití nuestro enviado especial Jorge
Hurtado visitó los mercados fronterizos
en el límite domínico haitiano y esto
encontró
cruzar para vivir cada lunes y viernes
esta puerta se abre en el puente que
divide República Dominicana y Haití
semanalmente pasan entre 10.000 a 20.000
haitianos para hacer Comercio en el
mercado binacional de dajabón
[Música]
en el Mercado La mayoría de comerciantes
son haitianos en busca de productos para
revender en su país pero algunos
haitianos se quejan del aumento de las
deportaciones reino vive del otro lado
del puente y recientemente fue detenido
pese a contar con sus documentos en
regla las autoridades
dan pasar a los nacionales haitianos y
por qué
nos recoge más adelante para devolverlo
se refiere a estos camiones repletos de
migrantes haitianos que son devueltos a
su país
la escena se repite casi a cada hora
en tiroli un mercado más pequeño
controlado por haitianos el dominicano
Teófilo Santana lleva 20 años haciendo
negocios con sus vecinos teme que la
inestabilidad en Haití afecte sus ventas
se ha programado no tenemos Libre como
como comercial habrá problema Entonces
tanto lo ha hecho más sufrir también
pero las opiniones son diversas cuando
se habla de una probable intervención
militar extranjera en Haití Yo pienso
que Haití desde hace mucho tiempo debió
ser intervenido porque Lamentablemente
Haití no está preparado para ser un país
democrático y esto da pena que yo tenga
que decirlo pero realmente es así Haití
es un país que tiene que vivir con una
mano dura el flujo de migrantes se
disparó en los últimos meses por la
inseguridad y el caos político en Haití
lo que llevó a Dominica reforzar sus
fronteras en 2022 más de 160.000
haitianos fueron retornados de República
Dominicana según el grupo de apoyo a
repatriados y refugiados organización
que afirma que al menos 60.000 de ellos
fueron arrestados antes de ser
deportados
los retornos son solo una de las medidas
que República Dominicana plantea para
controlar el tránsito de haitianos hacia
su país una más radical se levantan más
de 390 kilómetros de frontera común
nuestro periodista Jorge Hurtado viajó
hasta el noreste de la zona limítrofe
para retratar el avance de la
construcción de un polémico muro y la
reconfiguración territorial y social que
conlleva el mismo
Ramón Rivas y su esposa Rosa son una
pareja binacional que vive a las orillas
del río masacre en el noreste dominicano
se conocieron hace más de una década y
formaron su hogar donde ahora se
construye el muro fronterizo que
dividirá sus países de origen Este es el
muro viene aquí y mi casa es eso que
queda ahí
como les estaba contando no sé si a
nosotros nos vamos a mover O no pero no
me han dicho nada no estoy seguro de eso
pese a la incertidumbre y polémica
internacional que despierta la
construcción de Este muro para él es
sinónimo de seguridad para algunos dicen
que no que todo es un disparate para
mucha gente va a ser una protección muy
fuerte una seguridad
ambos porque como yo le dije no tengo
animales pero me siento más seguro más
protegido la frontera a pocos metros de
allí el significado del muro es muy
diferente para el haitiano saturne Álex
su vivienda y la de otros vecinos Fueron
demolidas por la construcción a los
demás los indemnizaron Pero él todavía
no recibe el pago y las autoridades no
dan una respuesta la única explicación
que encuentra es su estatus migratorio
toda la gente entrega su dinero pero a
mí todavía no entrega nada Y por qué
cree que es que yo no sé se dice
para firmar todo ese papel yo yo soy
ilegal es una verdad así para que yo
tengo el pasaporte no no tiene visa
Entonces yo yo era diciendo para recibir
su dinero falta que yo tengo residencia
por ahora saturnea y su familia viven
con unos vecinos cada día visita los
escombros de lo que fue su hogar con la
esperanza de recibir alguna noticia de
las autoridades dominicanas
era una vecina que entrega su dinero la
primera etapa de construcción del muro
con 54 kilómetros está avanzada según
las autoridades Ahora se prevé la
construcción de otros 110 kilómetros a
lo largo de la frontera común mientras
crecen las críticas de organismos de
Derechos Humanos que afirman que el muro
crearía xenofobia y racismo esos son
presiones
internacionales que nos quieren imponer
un guión una línea para unificar
estos dos poblados lo cual no será
posible porque son muchas razones que no
estén detalles aunque las opiniones
sobre el muro son diversas la mayoría
coinciden que ambas naciones tendrán un
antes y un después de su construcción
el flujo por la frontera que el gobierno
dominicano planea regular impacta
también a sus ciudadanos tan solo en
2021 República Dominicana compró
productos haitianos por un valor de
apenas cuatro millones de dólares pero
vendió más de 500 millones de Haití cómo
queda Entonces el comercio y qué pasará
con las familias binacionales hasta que
inmigrantes de France 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f-24 sigan
conectados con más información en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]